so I have the effortlessly cute look
going today you're right I don't I put a
lot of work into this sadly but honestly
I don't even eat pizza because I have a
lactose sensitivity what am i doing why
what is what is I am me what is me hello
welcome to this video my name is grace
Helbig if you didn't know now you know
your life is different now
my shoulder cracked just doing that if
you want any look into how athletic I am
it is July 6 2016 and the internet tells
me that today is international kissing
day this is how you do kissing it's
really difficult to learn about kissing
growing up but not now because you guys
have the Internet so it's actually not
difficult at all whatsoever I was just
projecting my own experience in my youth
God we only had books and gossip and
Napster there's a lot of ways to kiss
and I really don't feel like you'll ever
know until you do it it's like origami
regardless I thought it would do you
would disservice if I didn't make a
video teaching you some of the most
popular ways to kiss here we go
you
this just reminds me that I need to take
my garbage out there you go there are
some of the most popular ways to kiss
I'm happy to have been here to educate
you if you enjoyed this experience at
all whatsoever please subscribe to this
YouTube channel if you hated this
experience violently and deeply and
memorably please subscribe to this
YouTube channel you deserve it I deserve
it
thank you for being here I don't know
and happy international kissing day
what's Dumber this video or the fact
that that's an international holiday
this one's offensive right now let's say
Eskimo anymore right I'm just I'm a
well-intentioned girl and gene Simmons
makeup just trying to not hurt anyone's
feelings other than my parents for
realizing this is my job